the biggest issue is ambient anxiety oh
we need cat food should I hire a vice
president with finance should we get
divorced you know it's that it's all
that stuff and most people are willing
to tolerate that so it's the the biggest
issue out there is people's comfort and
familiarity with the ambient anxiety
that they live in
that looks like a particularly
precarious single stack of books that
you've got next to you okay I always
have to explain that it it happens to be
a bookshelf you can get in the u.s. from
a company called Design Within Reach
it's a very well designed bookshelf that
you can take stack books up and it
doesn't fall over but these are I'm not
gonna read these these this an archive
of all the books and all the different
translated languages Katherine we were
gonna throw them away when we move from
santa barbara de amsterdam six years ago
okay there's this oh come oh we should
keep it this one copy wheat so that's
that archive and it provides podcasts
you know back right yeah well it's the
problem with having having a book
translated into at 30 languages that
you've got just in terms of size you
know just sheer floor space it's gonna
take up a lot I know and we live in an
apartment in Amsterdam so like smaller
space best so anyway and it it does
create a topic for podcast so here we
are it looks like I'm not gonna like
just look a little bit like a health
hazard but now that you've reassured me
that it's not gonna fall over and kill
somebody then no we're cool yeah exactly
and so you're a man who's been thinking
about the problem of productivity for 40
years have you worked out why it's so
hard to get things done
well must be thought our okay it's not
hard to get things done people wouldn't
be listening to this that they can get
things done I already get anything's
done if you couldn't get anything done
you wouldn't get out of bed so
everybody's already getting things done
so I I you know what your you know what
you're alluding to is people going how
do I get more done with less effort how
do I leave work earlier how do I not
have quite so much stress how about you
know so it you know productivities got a
little baggage Chris as a as a concept
of but he thinks that's work Harbor but
you're already being productive you're
already producing Lee exactly what
you're getting people say be more
productive what they mean is I want to
be able to somehow get done what I get
what I'm getting done right now with
less effort leave work earlier have more
time with my kids you know whatever or
given the energy that put in I I want to
be able to produce more results more
money more relaxation more fun more you
know God does whatever people want so
yeah so I understand the issue you know
if you know what you're doing efficiency
and doing it more effectively is the
only improvement opportunity if you
don't know what you're doing figuring
out what you want to do is another it's
a big improvement opportunity so either
people know what they want they just
want to do it easier better or I'm not
sure what they want and so clarifying
that will you know be an increase in how
they feel they're they're more
productive or appropriately productive
absolutely yeah it's a it's a two-step
process a lot of people don't know what
they want to want and then upon deciding
what they want to want they then need to
work out how to what how to get the
thing that they've now decided that they
want it doesn't surprise me that people
kind of get lost and and can sometimes
struggle
well you know here's in the last couple
years Chris you know I've been doing
this for 35 years but in the last couple
of years I've really sort of understood
I to say the biggest problem was people
feeling overwhelmed and not knowing or
being able to do or being aware of what
they need to do to get out from under
the over well but I don't think that's
the issue the issue is not over well if
you were actually overwhelmed you'd
figure it out
you'd be overwhelmed Chris if your
building caught on fire right now
you know but you would then handle that
because you said I'm gonna survive so I
am gonna get rid of the overwhelmed
feeling because overwhelm is not
something that you can it's a very
sustainable you know psychological event
the biggest issue is ambient anxiety oh
we need cat food should I hire a vice
president with finance till we get
divorced you know it's that it's all
that stuff and most people are willing
to tolerate that so it's the the biggest
issue out there is people's comfort and
familiarity with the ambient anxiety
that they live in it's like the last
thing a fish notices is water and so the
last thing a lot of people notice is the
ambient anxiety that they've been in for
years
perhaps today we are going to open some
people's eyes to the ambience ambient
anxiety that they're swimming through I
have to say is well I do agree anyone
that knows what real high pressure
stress acute stress feels like knows
that it usually results in stuff being
done the student that stays up to do the
all-nighter just before they hand the
assignment in hands the assignment in
you know it's ambient anxiety which is
precluded the last six weeks since they
were given the assignment that's what's
caused the problem wait till you'd
suggest what went to your tears so if
you had to write a book
right all you needs a deadline that will
create the overwhelm that you're gonna
then handle but it's like oh my god the
book is not the the draft is not due for
three months ah oh my god I should be
writing bathe in this anxiety for a
little bit longer yeah well you get it I
do indeed
so you mentioned it earlier on the the
first edition of your book getting
things done came out 2001 nearly 20
years ago so why are you we still here
talking about it today what makes GTD so
special that it's continually getting as
I can see it more popular even 20 years
later well it works but it only works if
you want to change your world so that's
why we're back to people's addiction to
ambient anxiety there and there's not
like a guy I need more handy and anxiety
let me go shoot it up it should you're
used to it so you don't think there's a
better game and you're okay with what it
is you [ __ ] and moan about it but
you're okay with it you're very familiar
with it I'm so busy Holmes oh yeah well
that gives you you know a merit badge
Wow such a successful person that I'm so
busy that I can complain about it and
feel good and that's you know I'm sorry
most people just live in a life that's
okay with them okay enough
strange way so once you're a you know
again addiction just means you're used
to something so you're not aware that
there's another game there's another
world you could live in once you taste
that or taste that enough some part of
you will go oh my god you know there's
something on my mind right now I've got
to do something about it I got to write
it down I better decide the next action
I have to organize it appropriately so
that my brain is back to present and
clear again so you know what I
discovered was how do you get president
clear in a very very busy world and
that's my marketing issue you know I
tried and I'm trying to sell people
something they don't even know they need
I'm laughing because what Steve Jobs
sold you something you didn't know you
needed until you caught it mmm there's
something with a product rather than a
system there's something a lot more
tacit about that right there's something
that's quite visceral about it being
there you see it these are the objective
changes you can make you see the person
who has the iPod well what you got it
what you get in your head yeah of course
you don't see the GTD master walking
down the street and have this
externalized so socialized benefit with
there's no equivalent of the white air
pods for um for GTD right which would be
cool you should issue black belts
well we actually over the years we've
sort of designed okay you want to call
yourself a white belt yellow belt
Greenville brown belt black belt
here's if it relative GTD here's where
you are and what you're doing if you're
at that level of games so we've defined
it but it's not obvious yeah in it I got
to your point yeah yeah for sure
um have you seen how heated some of the
debates on the GTD reddit get no you
I'm not particularly interested anybody
who says this doesn't work it's just
they just not aware of it or there's not
old enough oh no no no this is less to
do with GTD doesn't where everyone on
the GTD reddit agrees that GTD works or
at least almost everybody does what they
argue over at the finest most fine
points about whether or not you can
schedule a next action for tomorrow can
I actually add it to my calendar no that
should be nested within your projects
and OmniFocus is better than things
three and blah blah blah it's a wall
zone in there it's a war zone what a
great audience argument to have yeah I'm
just I don't need to be bothered by it
it's called we laid out the game how
people play the game whether they want
to play on third base or first base and
whether they don't like to throw pitch
you know come on how you play the game
is very much up to you so it's
fascinating Christie to come up with a
model that gave you the total freedom
for how you implement it but but without
violating what the basic principles are
you can get stuff out of your head
however you want write it on your butt
you know I have hired 12 people to
follow you around and give it to them to
make sure that they trust they feed it
back to you when you need to see it you
know so that the model doesn't care how
you capture or how you review what it is
or what you put the results of you're
thinking about what you need to do about
it that's all up to you but the
principles are in violent I think that
the freedom within the system is
precisely where these debates can come
in because it's not it's just it's just
not quite prescriptive enough for
someone to be able to say no you're
wrong
and you're right there's like a almost
like a biblical interpretation that
needs to be done you need to get a
posture in right can we get a posture in
please
well sir well yeah okay so what what is
the principle in sight of GTD your heads
are crappy office so you need
get it out of your head you need to you
know clarify what it means you know put
the results in some trusted system
externally so that your brain is freed
up to make you know a strategic and
intuitive and intelligent decisions
about what to do but your head can't do
that you know your brain your if your
brain did not evolve to remember remind
prioritize or manage relationships with
more than four things now that's the new
data really since you see if you have
more than four things on your head that
you're trying to and that's the only
place you're trying to manage them
you're gonna be driven by latest in
latest strategic intuitive intelligence
and that's just data don't shoot the
messenger I'm just letting you know now
I discovered that 35 years ago on the
street I couldn't have told you that
exactly but the last ten years the
cognitive scientists have basically
validated and proved that so that's a
lot of what it is it's called don't use
your head as your office guys it's a
shitty office so you know you get the
stuff out of your head so that's a lot
of what the basics of this is there's a
lot more to it than that
in terms of how do you truly once you
get it out of your head a lot of people
make lists but they still don't manage
the list appropriately so there are
several steps to being able to truly
externalize your own commitments so this
is a lot about clarifying your
agreements with yourself that's a big
game you know Chris very few people have
truly identified all their agreements
for themselves
oh should I give my kids karate lessons
or not oh should I hire vice president
of research should I get divorce should
I should I manage that you know most
people just got an awful lot going
around banging on in their head they
have not identified clarified
objectified and organized the results of
their thinking about that and the
decision-making about that and that's
what's creating the ambient anxiety
which once it mounts up starts to become
this sort of source of just basic stress
that's killing people it makes for an
arduous life to have to assess each
decision individually each time it
occurs
and comes up right and also have to be
able to remember it recall it remember
how it relates to all of the other
interlocking things that you need to do
well once knowledge work showed up know
the great late Peter Drucker and
identified knowledge work where you
actually have to think to figure out
what to do as opposed to having it
self-evident when it shows up in terms
of what your work is but I don't know
Chris last time you went to your
physical mailbox did the mail identify
itself as junk mail or not know you had
to figure that out right but the last
time you open your email and look at it
did any of those say this is junk mail
reading if you dare or care no in force
you you had to actually think about
things you've you've have you know
implicitly allowed into your echo system
like I don't I don't care about what you
is in your email Chris but you don't
care what's in mine you care what's in
yours because you've now allowed that
into your world so now that you've
allowed input into your world that is
potentially meaningful to you but you
don't know yet what exactly it does mean
to you that's where this methodology
that I uncovered discovered codified
comes into play you want to get that off
your mind you can go back to survival
mode you if you're in a crisis you
actually relax because it gets rid of
all those decisions if you're not in a
physical crisis your your your the
building is not on fire then there's a
bigger crisis all the demons of the gate
are allowed to rush through Chris what
could you be doing instead of talking to
David right now you could be doing this
but oh my god and what do you do out
come on the stress of opportunity is
what's killing a lot of people these
days
that's where the technology and the
change in the technology has made a
difference nothing really
technology hasn't really made a huge
difference in productivity after word
processes and spreadsheets they changed
the world but since then primarily the
only big change has been connectivity
volume and speed of input right that's
what your that that's what your
technology has allowed so now you've got
a whole lot more stuff coming at you
that you have to decide about that you
have to make a decision about how
valuable is it how do I engage with it
what do I do with that what come on when
I was 14
sixty years ago I spent two hours on the
phone with my girlfriend right what's
the difference between that and let
yourself down with Facebook or Instagram
whatever that's a human experience right
so the the issue is that you may have
sixteen girlfriends now and have sixteen
different channels that you could use to
interact leave it is not David if you're
not referring to me to people who are
listening that's obviously someone with
far lower morals than I do
yeah that makes sense Chris yeah
absolutely
you know there's implicit questions
people have you know like a what's
changed that's what's a it's further
down what what has changed since you
first wrote GTD you're reading my notes
here but I totally get it the I think
this answers the question of why pillow
people still talking about GTD why's a
system that people are still interested
in which is that the principles scale
they scale across technology they scale
across volume across intensity and what
we've seen if there was going to be a
stress test for your system it would be
the smartphone with social media and
always-on communication
sure
no no and I still have to grapple with
that how much door it's time to I would
spend on Instagram and you know I wake
up in the morning and you know along
with my you know French press coffee and
you know in the New York Times front
page I would say I buy iPad I play a few
games have in store you know of words
with friends across the point and still
check in on history on to see but you
know a few friends minored seeing you
know looking around in their world and
see what they're doing you know why not
no come on it's like a it's like but to
me social media is like a cocktail party
you don't want to spend your life in a
cocktail party you know unless of course
you can afford to do that and like to do
that that's fine or just to what degree
is that fun to keep you inspired keep
you engaged keep you in connected to the
world to what degree is that distraction
from what you do be doing in your life
but that's that's not designed that's
not decided by the technology that's
produced as a challenge and a choice you
have to make given given the
opportunities you have I really like the
idea of the fact that the number of
opportunities we have has upregulated
this ambient anxiety I recently had Greg
McKeown author of essentialism on and he
says something very similar that success
breeds options and opportunities and
those options and opportunities
undermine the things which often led to
success in the first place sure welcome
hi Chris go be innovative
I'm trying I'm go right now you'll be
innovative I'm troubled but I got it
innovation doesn't happen by people who
would not to be innovative it happened
because the people figured out how to
get that what you're drinking in that
kind of can it came it came about by
people trying to figure out okay here's
this here's here's an issue here's an
opportunity here's something that we
need to have and we don't have those
things to do that so it's been
challenges and then triggers the
creative thinking you know in your brain
to produce some sort of a new result or
something you've different way to do
that so yeah the whole idea of
innovation and change shows up because
of needs not because of somebody wants
to just be different yeah I get that so
I want to get into the process of how we
can get things done but first can you
explain to us what is mind like water
your psyche is not over or under
reacting to anything it's totally
present with no distractions with full
capability to be aware and engage all of
your resources for whatever is present
that has your attention at the moment
and that is enabled by getting things
out of your head into a system enabled
by getting rid of anything that's that's
distracted potentially distracting to
you or sucking wind out of your sails
psychologically so yes you know if four
people jump you in a dark alley you do
not want to have 2000 unprocessed emails
hanging around your head no you don't I
had Paul bloom psychologist at Yale on
and he's writing a new book about why
people enjoy pain and he interviewed a
dominatrix who said nothing captures
attention like a whip and he relates it
to the same reason that people do BASE
jumping and why people like doing things
with such scaled-up highly regulated
highly up regulated levels of sensory
input because it forces them into the
present the 2000 on wedding males they
got to go because you've just been hit
in the face with a whip you know and
that reminds me right back to the first
thing he said at the very beginning
which is this change from overwhelmed to
ambient anxiety and I really considering
I've never heard it before I think I
think you might be onto something there
what just talk to my dermatologist the
reason you would like to scratch an itch
is because itches come from a different
part of your brain than pain does and
when you scratch it it creates more pain
than the itch created and it allows you
to get temporary relief from the itch
because then your brain gets to engage
with how do I deal with pain but then
when you stop scratching at a certain
point in time the itch comes back
because the that didn't handle it so if
you want a micro example just
physiologically about what you just said
there it is
I like it okay so the process how can we
get things done well first of all you
have to define what does what done means
it's a silly question to ask if you
don't know what done means how do we get
what done
thinking about a divorce potentially but
what has done mean divorced not
necessarily
it may mean clarification or resolution
of this issue between me and my life
partner right so there's a there's a
challenge to define what done means what
does done mean if you're thinking any
kind of issues relative to your
profession your business or whatever and
many times done means just getting
resolution about whether or not this is
something to do so done oftentimes it's
just a research project I need to figure
out whether we should hire a consultant
to lead us through this whole
organizational change I need to look
into whether or not you know I should
merge with this business as a gate maid
it's an offer that I don't think is
quite you know rich enough
right and most people don't really
identify those kind of things as
projects so what has done me and most
people are banging you know got all
kinds of stuff banging around their head
you know Johnny my kid wants to take
karate lessons on a motion to give me
he's only eight years old so to give
them a car you know way what it's done
me resolve that question but is there in
successful resolving the question
absolutely what's the next action what
would you need to first of all you need
to define okay I need to get clear about
whether to give Johnny karate lessons or
not that's my outcome right and you
could decide not to give Johnny karate
lessons and check that office done the
result so the equivalent for the divorce
would be spend sufficient time with my
wife that we no longer need to get
divorced resolution what well that would
be the action step you might want to
take or the things you might need to do
to get to that right now just get ahead
of myself I'm sorry but the resolution
would be you know cruise control in my
relationship with Susan with Johnny with
whatever alright so I want to put this
onto cruise control so you know if you
and your listeners or people are
watching this if you understand what
cruise control means I mean this thing
is on automatic I don't need to have my
attention on this anymore because I'm
trusting what's going on in the process
going on out there right yeah you know
you're pumping your blood Cris and your
breathing is on cruise control you're
not you're not worried about whether
you're gonna breathe or not I mean you
could be if you're given the other stuff
going on but right now that's all fine
so what's not on cruise control well you
don't have to go very far called what's
popped into your head while we've been
talking that has nothing to do with
well-being talking about
so anybody listening to this wherever
your heads gone oh you know they
mentioned this but I need ya I need you
that ah not yet on cruise control
as soon as you think I need cat food
twice you're not appropriately engaged
with your cat
but you and cat are not on cruise
control yet okay
as soon as anything pops into your head
unless you just like the thought and
many times I'm just thinking about stuff
because I like thinking about I'm just
kind of grazing and just looking around
my life but anything keeps popping my
head I should I need to that lightbulb
means changing that thing needs to be
doing oh my god you know what am I going
to do about the X Y Z those are the
things that are not on cruise control
yet and that's what you need to identify
if you wanted to start to get really
clear because what's in the way of clear
are those things for which the right
decisions had not been made and the
right content has not been parked in the
appropriate places so your brain your
brain can love it so your brain can let
it go I'm just gonna let the listeners
pause on that for a second because the
first time that I heard the concept that
the only thought that you should ever
have more than once a thoughts that you
choose to think that you want to think
that that in itself is a ground shaking
insight it may not be for it may not be
for you as the 12th dan black belt
Brazilian jiu-jitsu GTD master David
Allen
but for 24-year old me swimming in the
advent of fresh Instagram launch and 140
character Twitter and all this sort of
stuff I was at hang on a second
I think things multiple times per second
that I don't want to think
I'll get a thought get rid of it and get
it again within the space of minutes and
to hear that that's not just par for the
course that's not just standard
operating procedure was a very very big
insight into everyone that's listening
think about how many of the thoughts you
have per day that you don't want to have
do you have multiple times delay it's
okay as long as you get into the Zen of
okay that's okay that I don't do
anything about that I'll let that keep
popping in and just kind of enjoy the
process and then see whether it actually
emerges into something real or not
you will speed up the process if you
sort of apply this principle of
externalizing that so that some part of
you trust
oh I'll I'll be reminded of that cool
joke I might want to use somewhere else
or I'll be reminded of that thing I
might want to do at some point but I
parked it in an appropriate place so
that my brain goes ah okay I know what I
walked through the door in the morning
it's in the front of the door the thing
I needed to take the more office
tomorrow so when you're smart and have
creative thinking and creative thoughts
that might be appropriate and productive
for your life
you know if you're if you're really cool
you park those in some appropriate place
so that one so so that when you're not
so duck not so smart you're kind of dumb
and thick you actually do smart things
so that was another thing I discovered
over all these years it's like you know
they're really smart and sophisticated
people just realize they're not smart
and sophisticated all the time actually
in very rare moments but when you're
smart and sophisticated you capture the
results of that thinking and then part
the results in place so that when you're
kind of thick and dumb which we are most
the time you actually do smart stuff
right now I hope you people can play
that back and listen to that about 45 45
this is one of those constant replay if
you're listening on Apple podcasts or
Spotify there's a little button just to
the left of the play button which
rewinds by 15 to 30 seconds and if you
just or if you're on Siri you can say
hey Siri please go back by fit by 60
seconds this is how I skipped through
been Shapiro's abs on his podcast but
for this one you may need to go back a
couple of times so okay we we know that
our mind is built for having thoughts
not holding thoughts we know that we
need know you you do not know you know
we say we know that oh come on we in the
listeners now no you are slowly red
peeling as all as this podcast goes on
David okay this is the it sorry the
insight that you have given us is that
our mind is built for having thoughts
not a whole lot we need to define what's
done would look like
yeah yep why are we next well if you had
nothing else to do but move toward that
done where would you go right now and
what would you do physically visibly the
very mouths thing Wow I think we might
need to get divorced okay desired
outcome clarify relationship with life
partner
okay what's the very next thing you we
need to do if you had nothing else to do
and remedy I'm gonna pay you a million
pounds or a million dollars or a million
euros or whatever to just start moving
on that right now nothing else what
would you do would you go to him or her
and have a conversation would you call
your attorney would you surf the web and
see eg what I'm going to do about this
would you say I need to give myself two
hours of a blocked out time to just
meditate about this issue about what I'm
going to do so you need to decide what's
the very next thing you would need to do
to move the needle toward that outcome
what's the next action so Chris and
listeners come on guys the zeros and
ones of productivity outcome in action
what do you want as a final outcome as
an either material outcome or an
experience that you want and what's the
very next physical visible action or
activity or focus you need to have in
order to move the needle toward that and
those two things are the things most
sophisticated people listed for this are
avoiding like the plague about all kinds
of stuff in their head
I just discovered the algorithm outcome
an action so what's the outcome of
potential divorce what's the actual step
you need to take what's the outcome of
cat needs food what's the action
somebody needs to take and and so the
clarification step so as you know Chris
you know that I just identified I didn't
make it up I just identified the five
steps we need to do to get anything
under control you need to capture what's
got your attention what's not okay to
control identify what that is and then
clarify step two what do I need to do
about it is it actionable on and is
there some outcome or action I need to
identify about that step three is
organized reminders of the bad if you
can't finish them in the moment step
four is to make sure you've got that
some in some sort of trusted external
system that you can reflect on and
review when it's time to run errands
when it's time to just sit down and talk
to whoever you talked about or stood on
your computer what are all the things
that I might should would ought to do
Step five is then you know make choices
about all that given that you've done
step one through four so you know that
was that was a longer answer than what
you asked about but that was it I mean
that's basically the getting things done
process captured clarify organized
reflect and engage because that's how
you get your kitchen under controls how
you get your consciousness under control
but most people will do that for the
kitchen but they haven't done that with
their consciousness yet
in the GTD framework from those five
steps where do people tend to find the
most challenge all the way across just
across the board there's no leaks or no
peaks and troughs across the board the
first challenge is people don't get
stuff all get everything out of their
head so they don't trust anything
they're actually they don't trust their
external brain they don't trust their
lists because they know there's still
stuff other than that so the first
that's a parts list yeah it's a most
people have some stuff out of their head
they've been some sort of a to-do list
but they got a whole lot of other stuff
they haven't written down so they don't
trust either place you don't trust your
head or your list right so then you drop
all around and just fumble around and
deal with Legation loudest you know so
that's step you know that's the first
place people fall off second places even
people make lists everybody listening to
this has some sort of version of a to-do
list but they haven't decided what to do
about the stuff on their to-do list
they've got mom or bank or VP of wife
and Finance or whatever you know if
they've written if they've captured all
the stuff to begin with it good for them
they haven't decided okay so now what
you know what's the outcome what's the
action step you need to take about that
if any so the second thing people fall
off is they haven't determined what to
do about their to do most peoples to-do
lists create as much stress as they were
leave because when they look at it they
go god there's thinking and decisions
about mom's birthday or the bank in
inventory or you know oh you know
whatever and they haven't decided about
it so that I don't want to be able to
look at it it just reminds them they're
overwhelmed
third step is people have made you sigh
I need to call my sister about mom's
birthday but they didn't Park that
somewhere they'll trust they'll see at
the right time so now it's parked back
up in their head which has no sense of
past or future of this creating the
ambient anxiety I got this stuff I
didn't do my mom's birthday I think I
decided to call my sister bro wakes him
up at 3 o'clock the morning Conner you
need to call my sister oh my god so you
know they could fall off there too and
then they could fall off even if they'd
done all that when you find a few people
that done it but even people who've
captured everything clarified everything
organized everything then they don't
look at their external brain system
wherever that is some sort of a list
manager whatever they're managing all
that and they're still driven off latest
and oddest you know so they're not
actually engaging with their thing if
it's a strange paradox you actually have
to use your mind to empty your mind so
in order to be present you need to look
at everything you've thought about
everything you've decided about and see
that as an external inventory and go no
I'm gonna have a beer and no I'm gonna
take a nap no I'm not going to do any of
that I need to sit down and design a new
business plan so you know then people
fall off there they don't actually use
their system as an external brain
your external brain only works if it
actually is an external brain not just
some externalized dump thing you've
stuck stuff in that you're not engaging
with appropriately
I guess I could go a little but those
are the main reasons that people may not
stick with this as a as a black though
so they find particular obstacles each
stage along the way I really find it so
hilarious and very true that a
unclarified unreviewed and organized
to-do list just becomes kind of like a
monument to all of the ambient anxiety
exactly you've created this sculpture
out of all of the things that were
causing you anxiety in your head and now
look at them okay so I think hopefully
the audience will be getting it into
their heads that it is better for us to
have the things we need to do out of our
heads and down somewhere that some of
thing needs to be clarified that
clarification then needs to be organized
the organizing step from clarifying
something to organizing how can someone
go about that don't think unless you
have a systems mentality I don't think
that's a supernatural way to to put
things together well anybody who's ever
made a list of stuff to buy the store
who's already doing this anybody who has
a calendar is already doing this so
people complain about all the lists I
suggest they go well then throw away
your calendar or your diary and they
don't be intellectually dishonest if you
think your head can do it all let your
head do it all
oh you're maintaining a diary or a
calendar oh why Oh cuz I don't want to
miss that appointment no kidding
I understand
so the the specifics of categorizing
anything you don't put the plans for
your divorce on the shopping list to go
to the shop of course not
you just need to decide what the next
action is to make a decision about
whether to get divorced not in some
place you'll see at the right time and
place
what about if I've got tons of next
actions
I got million different projects going
on when you don't have a million you
have 3200 okay wife I got 30 next
actions and I'm looking at them all and
I think well I need to sort this divorce
out but the cat the cats starving but oh
I haven't done this I haven't done this
how do i prioritize prey trust your
inner voice that says mmm I'm not sure
what to do let me pick an easy one to do
so I still stay in the saddle of my life
as opposed to being the victim of it or
let me chew the tough one to deal with
that ugly email I've been avoiding
trying to respond to so that I can then
snack on email the rest of the day as a
reward
either one take your pick
I do either herb I do both of those so
you have to then trust your intuition
about which thing would be would
potentially create the most value or the
create you know get me back on to my
appropriate you know in this saddle of
my life again most appropriately and it
could be the hardest it could be the
easiest many times I flipped between
both of those so I have no formula for
that
I like the again this these degrees of
freedom I think are the flexibility the
GTD has which obviously is is fuel for
the reddit discussions but it also does
make it scalable it does make it
flexible it would allow it to work for
somebody that's house mom at home versus
guy that needs VP thing doing needs blah
blah so ok so we've got ourselves into
it being organized now we have organized
the things that are out of our heads
that we have clarified we have them in
two different sections different sub
project the divorce project and which
sounds terrible that sounds like it that
sounds like a really bad TV show doesn't
it
I've been through three so I know them
well so that could be the next business
coach at GTD method for a divorce
number four what where do we go we have
organized what are we doing reflect and
review the context
only relax about what's out of your head
when you look at what you got out of
your head on some consistent basis you
can only feel comfortable about the
errands you need to run if you look at a
list of errands you've come up with over
the last week or two
alright you can only feel comfortable
about what you need to talk to your boss
or your business partner or your life
partner about if you look at what you've
come up with over the last week or two
that you need to talk to him or her
about but the alternative would be the
equivalent of writing the things you
need to do in a glass bottle caulking it
putting it in the sea but actually
that's okay as long as some part of you
says I don't have to or need to see that
and would be love to see that whenever
that bottle shows up on some beach okay
so you could potentially create a GTD
system someone out there I'll be able to
program this there probably well after
this progress whereby it's a little bit
like a quote of the day or a vocabulary
builder thing where you just put in 365
random tasks and it just issues you one
of these random tasks a day and you're
like look at this yesterday today I'm
getting divorced yeah you know my OB
ultimate GTD digital you know high-tech
system would be you walk in the room
goes oh Chris it's Friday afternoon
three o'clock
here's what you usually do in a Friday
afternoon at three o'clock you know here
are your options you know pick one and
that you walk up the hologram pick that
and then all of a sudden that shows up
with all the context around those kinds
of things well Friday afternoons I
usually think about my family
great you hit that you suddenly see a
hologram all your family just around you
right there yeah Oh Susan God punch on
Susan Susan's birthday her favorite
colors what she loves to do whatever so
you want to know a real review process
or reflection process the technology's
not even close yet
ah slash computer science are you
listening to David Allen this is this is
a semi-formal request from the modern
wisdom podcast we get this system
created okay do you get that Chris yeah
I say that I go and people don't cuz
people go what's the ultimate system I
say that would be the ultimate system so
your mind doesn't have to think about
what it needs to think about
you've already programmed what you want
to think about when you want to think
about it and it built in a system that
then makes you not have to worry about
what you need to think about when you
need to think about it you've already
decided that nothing and you built that
in that's something that I've never
thought about before but genuinely for
knowledge work would be a phase shift it
would be a complete because I don't
think that the vast majority of
knowledge workers struggle at doing
things they struggle at knowing what
they need to do when there's a task in
front of you we identified it earlier on
that the the very peak end of
Parkinson's Law just the night before
the the dissertation that's worth fifty
percent of the fifty thousand pound
degree that you've paid for is due in
you are no problem right in the woods
the words are coming easy as hell then
but it's the choosing when to do it
what's example it's actually the next
action that I need to do do any onion
speak to them I got this other thing to
do etc etc that would be with the
reminder to do that thought process at
the right toe
that's your meta process when should I
be reminded to do that kind of thinking
right and then you control that
to having it not see where or whatever
that's forces you to have to think about
this you know whatever no no you design
your own program
believe me I've worked with some of the
smartest and brightest on the planet to
try to figure out could we do that
software wise guy yet no didn't work
there was no venom minimal Viable
Product we could produce given the
market that was going on the interest in
the market that would make it worthwhile
to invest all the resources to actually
make something like that happen that's a
shame because that would be
yes very cool very very very very very
cool okay what's on it yeah so if you
have it if you have a tech audience
listening to this I know okay guys I
gave it up I've tried twice to design
digital stuff that would optimize your
your thinking process and neither work
they all had all these they understood
these principles but the market wasn't
ready the technology wasn't ready to do
it
if you said gee I need to call David by
Friday where would you put that right
now things three you need to call David
by Friday and where would you put that
yeah that's the problem you don't have
anything right now at hand I do all
right
but but that's because I got a friend
that designed you know an overlay to
deliver Stokes you know years ago that I
still use I just go called David they be
in my calls list by Friday there be a
due date on that and so Friday would be
it would automatically show up that if I
hadn't done it by Friday that'd be a
little ding he shows up in my opinion
yeah so so you know what do you need to
do to organize the thought process the
knowledge work thinking and
decision-making you need to do and
technology is way behind there are a lot
of tools that are out there I got a lot
of people that use Excel or word or you
know the 300 or plus apps that have been
designed around GTD they're all list
managers yeah so you could do versions
of that you could you could kind of
create some workarounds they could make
that happen but nothing that's really
slick that full frictionless before
frictionless thing yeah what that would
be that would be so cool I can't so
that's the sort of thing that I liked it
that is a thought which I want to have
more than once a day that's one of the
you know just thinking about that world
thinking about walking in and the call
being do you want to call David you need
to tell him how well received the
podcast press on them there we go and
we're away that would be that'd be
wonderful okay so we not only that you
want to know you know what David's
wife's name is what his dog's name is
you also want to be able to see you know
what David has done you know since you
talked to him the last that might be out
there and Instagram were also gonna
aggregate the Social Feeds
has the book shall fear falling over and
it killed somebody has been you know god
bless their actually any one of these
little parcels that we're talking about
people have actually done versions of
that we've got somebody on your calendar
and they automatically sort of curate
whatever's out there in the social media
or
ever about them you know and so now
anything so if you had six gazillion
dollars the technology is there right
now you could sit down and design
exactly what we're talking about just
the mark the carbon markets going who
the frig cares me right me I do you have
a market of at least one I can promise
you you're not in enough pain yet I
don't know what I've been through David
you don't know where I've you don't know
the pain and the overwhelm and the
ambient anxiety ah so all you need to do
is get really uncomfortable with your
ambien anxiety and I will that will give
you sufficient motivation
okay so how often should we review how
often should we reflect on the the
organized clarified list as often as you
need to to make sure you're present with
whatever you're doing is that a typical
cadence to that yeah typical cadence we
talk about the week you review once a
week you need to kind of bring up the
rear garden circle wagons and say okay
what's happened or my list current is my
external brain you know current enough
so I can trust it so yeah there is a
kind of a seven-day cycle about sort of
regrouping things we've just seen
anecdotally but I read several years ago
that after about seven to eight days
your brain dumps a lot of context
so if you've tried to recreate what
happened in the meeting five days ago
you can probably pretty much do that
pretty well you know 15 days ago you did
can't do it which actually means that
you then need to create
more thorough you need to add context
into the things that you're taking out
of your brain if your review process is
more than seven days yeah sure because
your ability to understand what you're
talking about
has gone right well my Sunday maybe list
I probably don't need to see every seven
days probably every you know two or
three or four weeks I need to review the
stuff I think I might want to do but not
now so whatever the whatever your
commitment is about whatever the content
is that that's going to define your
recursion of review how often do you
need to review what you're doing with
your life with you and any life partner
you have if you have long how often do
you need to review the purpose of your
company and what you're doing how often
do you so all these reviews as you
probably know identified the six
horizons we have commitments there's
purpose there's vision there's goals and
objectives there's areas of
accountability there's projects there's
actions so those are different contexts
they're different horizons that you
actually need to identify what's the
what are the ingredients of all those
different levels we have commitments
with ourselves and then review those as
often as you need to how often do you
need to look at your calendar
or probably every depends on how you
know how intricate your calendar is or
how many content how much content you
have in it sometimes I need to look at
it several times a day sometimes once
every two days depends you know now with
the pandemic going on only need to like
my calendar
you know once a day and kind of for you
oh yeah I got this one I get this
podcast with Chris coming up yeah okay
yeah that's cool highlight of the day
obviously of course couldn't wait thank
you thank you
okay so we've realized that we need to
review a typical cadence of being around
about once a week appears to tally up
with a little bit of neuroscience and is
probably a good way it's certainly
something I've leveraged with this show
when I first started it I wanted to
always release it the same day at the
same time I wanted it to be ready for
people to wake up on a Monday morning so
that it would become a part of their
week so that I could automate their
habit of listening to this show as much
as I could and potentially if a Monday
morning or if a Sunday evening or a
wherever is I would caveat that actually
and I would say that Friday afternoon
tends to be a bad time to try and do a
review I don't think that that would be
a particularly effective time to it's
actually probably a good effective time
for a lot of people early Friday have to
do not late yep all right so you get to
kind of debrief your week you know and
get ready for the weekend and not have
anything sort of hanging them you know
so you can enjoy some relaxed time but
I've had people do weekly reviews Sunday
night some of some people do Monday
morning
some people do Thursday night so that
they sort of clean it everything up so
that the Friday and the weekend are
highly effective and you know so it
doesn't matter but you have to decide
what what do you need to do an alpha do
did to see what in terms of content how
often it's that simple how often do you
see your calendar how often do you need
to look at your goals for your company
how often should you look at you know
what you're doing in your life in terms
of year how's your health how's your
vowed to have vitality how's your
relationships how's your fun factor
how's your dog you know how's your
relation you know you know you know as
soon as those things started to pop into
your head sort of regularly Cannell gee
uh I should be doing something about
that you might want to have some sort of
a checklist checklists are the key to
life you know in a way one of the things
that I'm smart enough to figure out what
are the things I need to think about
what I go do a heart surgery or you know
when we're going on vacation but I need
to look at so I don't have to keep
rethinking about that it's a lot of it
is just building and again the external
brain and the external brain just needs
to be built in with enough content and
then the external brain will only bring
the value of the external brain if you
engage with the external brain
appropriately
I like the the analogy between control
and spontaneity that is given by having
things out of your brain because to
someone who maybe hasn't fully swallowed
the GTD red pill yet the idea of having
a checklist for everything you saying
the words like checklists our life might
sound well that doesn't sound very fun
or creative or spontaneous that just
sounds like a life where I've got to
write lists all the time right so
anybody who is doing this who's ever
looked at a recipe and said I'm glad to
have that recipe but here's what I want
I want to add a little extra pepper to
that I want to add I think we should add
a little more soy to that the recipe
that's what we're talking about but if
you didn't have the recipe you wouldn't
do that
you've just got pepper or soy in a pan
and who wants to eat that no one wants
to eat David all right okay so the final
number five how can we then move
ourselves past just reviewing trust your
gut or your spirit or the still small
voice inside of you or your liver or
whatever you trust when you look at it
go I'm going to do that not that
you
I do think I'll use intuition it's
probably the most generically consumable
digestible term about what I just said I
do think that there is a lot of
modern hyper rationalization about
things that can be fixed with gut
instinct Tim Ferriss has this concept
that he talks about for a note-taking
process that he used to be very very
into um so he would read a lot of books
and he wouldn't want to forget the
things that he read and then after a
long time of consuming information and
as he called it I think ruthlessly
indexing he came up with a rule and the
rule was the good [ __ ] sticks and that
is intuition right that is good instinct
that is yeah it well good as long as
you've matured you're you're digestible
prostitution process of what that was
and how real it was and so matured
meanings I've looked at it I've seen how
it could apply to me I'm letting that
sort of incorporate internally and then
you allow that to then you know kind of
rule or run you know what you notice or
what you consider important later on so
there's a there's a very very simple
formula for that Chris to make sure that
that works it's called get older that
was what I was gonna say there is a base
level of context that you need to have
in order to frame new wisdom that you
then add into it exactly well so thank
you I try I tried that's the polite ride
to say things well as much as I can okay
um so you've taken us through obviously
there is so much to go through and we
couldn't have gone through a full thing
in just a an hour-long podcast but I got
a couple a couple more questions to wrap
up um this is from Johnny who's one of
the co-hosts of the show and is
transitioning into full GTD mode and he
says what is your morning startup
process
you sit down to work how do you decide
what you don't want to down to work I
sit down to drink my lemon water to
begin with the cleanses system and my
French press coffee to just sort of
kickstart my brain a little bit I play a
little bit of words with friends around
the world and it would take sort of
kickstart my brain I read the front page
of the New York Times on my iPad and
take the dog out for what she needs to
do and then I sit down and go hmm what
it's the best thing to do right now and
then I just you know engage in a
reflection of all the stuff that's out
there in terms of my commitments um all
the you know multiple commitments I have
an interest that I have and then I make
a spontaneous decision about what to do
that's cool Johnny actually live me
after that my day starts the night
before the night before I look at my
calendar say okay what's the hard
landscape mainly because I like to sleep
as long as I can I'm a big sleep fan and
so the night before I look at the next
day or two
to get a sense of what are my external
commitments that I actually need to keep
up with to make sure that that's true
that gives me the relaxation then that
night to be able to say how long can I
sleep or whatever and also let's be kind
of especially if it's a busy week these
days with the pandemic I don't have that
much going on you know two or three or
four things a day that are committed
already comes your time but I need to
look at that and then relax that okay
that's cool I understand what the hard
landscape is so then in the morning when
I go through my little rituals with all
what I'd put attentions there's part of
me that says okay so here's where I need
to be now and here's how I manage that
so I'm usually kind of a 24 hour ahead
looking at just describing the landscape
to myself so I think internally you know
my hypothesis and a lot of good data
showing up lately with the cognitive
scientists is sleeping on things is a
really good idea yeah so if you are able
to look ahead to the next 1 2 3 4 days
or week ahead in your mind before you go
to sleep there's a part of you that
doesn't feel surprised by those things
as they're showing up and has already
sort of accumulated whatever unconscious
stuff we accumulate you know in the
sleep state which they've discovered is
a lot that that helps a lot I really
like the idea of liberating yourself
from the surprise of things happening
that you fly even even stuff that you've
planned especially as a good example
with this podcast it involves a lot of
scheduling I've got I've got a Julia
Cameron lady that wrote the artists way
I've got her on the show and that's been
booked in for two and a half months
like two and a half months for something
and you think like if I hadn't checked
the calendar I would have just woken up
on Friday I've been like speaking to a
lady that solds like 4 million bucks on
Friday like I got to do a thing I gotta
try and think of a thing for her
so yeah that that is status liberating
to have that and the day the night
before thing I think is is a good way to
do it reminds you it gives you context
right more acute context sure how's my
day going to fit together can I actually
train first thing in the morning or
would it be a little bit of a better
idea for me to you know and you wake up
in that in that way so I'm final
question I'm gonna guess that you get
asked this all the time are you rolling
bigamy I've never had anybody ask a
final question that was their final
question sure
I'm curious do you think this really is
final question is probably going to be
why can people follow you online but
that's a footnote that's in the appendix
so this is the final question of the
chapter okay I'll try and make it the
final key and if it's not this isn't
this is my rules welcome I well David
yeah exactly
because are you are you rolling with
some custom coded crazy David Allen made
by Silicon Valley direct app across all
of your devices for you to have your
productivity system embedded to manage
all of your tasks no
what are you using I use we still use
what was the old lotus notes became IBM
notes us now HCM notes I still use a you
know a group app that we use our small
little company and a friend of mine who
is my CTO for 10 years built an overlay
of that called a Productivity that you
know makes my task management within
that system you know more sort of GTD
esque so that's what I use for my
reminder system it's it justice it's a
sophisticated version of what if you
were using Outlook or anything that had
just a task management you know a
function so I use that and then I use
all the standard stuff I use stagette to
grab screenshots I used Evernote for a
lot of just random email stuff I use I
use word I use Excel for you know all
kinds of stuff I you and I use that just
by in you know my organized you know
computerized inventory of those things
how those those are structured within
the within the within that context and
what else I used the brain which is a
fascinating it's more of an informal
thing that I used for making random
connections with things what's not the
brain the brain yeah just look at the
brain the pH EB raim dot-com when we're
Harlow's is a friend of mine and and
knows my stuff it's a great way to sort
of build a software that sort of
connected oh eggs what does it remind me
of oh that reminds me of Susan who cooks
eggs
that reminds me by the way of a source
for eggs and you were able to connect
all those things and see them however
you want to see them so you know it's a
sort of a connectivity tool if you're
and they're there several out there they
could they could probably use in that in
that regard what else I use those of
them I think those those are the main
tools these
there you go the Internet has it sighs
I'm sorry
capture pen and paper no these are new
things nobody's ever heard about but
there's a pen that actually holds you
know information it holds you know data
that you can then actually put on to
this thing called paper most of you have
never seen this before it's actually oh
my god I can actually externalize this
stuff into a physical thing tell-tell
Christ God cast was fantastic number one
just write that in big capital letters
at the top save it is that one of those
fancy pens that writes upside-down
No one of those space pens and the
Russian over the Russians were just like
I will just make it one that took me ten
years to discover the best pen to sign
my books terms of autographs oh I will
have some authors from American
listening what is that it's just it's a
oh in bis it's an on base it's a I'll
send you a link to link will be authors
people who need to sign things link will
be in the show notes below is that
Lovers Only or inside pages on paper
inside pages where if it's a paperback a
lot of the other pins that people give
people as authors designed books with or
either too big or too small
they either bleed all over the page or
or they're too tiny then you need to
make a little more of an impact on that
so this is a what do they call it sorry
it's casing right now but it's it's one
of those things that it's just the right
amount of that thickness and it's so
it's not it's not the same as the other
like a sharpie marker pen but also not
quite as thin as if it was a ballpoint
you type thing exactly so if I write on
this how I can see yeah it comes out
just the right kind of width to nice
amount of weight that really makes you
know that you that was David Allen that
signed this book David that's right
that's the that is the signature of a
Mandan 100 facing a camera who has
signed an awful lot of his name on many
more than but lovely got what a great
problem had had the book to say man look
David I could go on I could go on all
day but thank you so much my my final
final final final question is I told you
this is the appendix this video you're
not this isn't part of that this is
outside of the rules where should people
go they think this GTD thing sounds good
I liked this really really charming
fella that Chris brought on the podcast
why did they go
they'd find out more well that'd be the
debit getting things done calm you'll
see an overview of what we've created as
a company right now after all these
years we mostly supporting our partners
around the world that are delivering you
know public seminars as well as you know
a lot of business to business
you know seminars inside of businesses
where they're you know teaching and
training and coaching this methodology
so you'll see that on our website you
can you can you know surf around that
we've got a free newsletter you can sign
up for
and of course you know you can always go
get the book getting things done we just
produced the getting things done
workbook it's also available in
bookstores around the world in the UK as
well
that's kind of the easy way to get
involved with its methodology if you're
not already there so just go take a look
link will be in the show notes below the
updated version of getting things done
which was done in 2015 I think and then
gained things done workbook plus getting
things done calm and at GTD guy on
Twitter yep GTD guy on Twitter in the
Allen 45 Israel if you want to see both
on my personal life a living at pictures
everything will be linked in the show
notes below David man it's been this
been wonderful thank you for you time a
crisis was really fun yeah thanks
[Music]
you